Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David P.
Our friend Billy Harrison called
in. He really thinks Keystone XL
would lower gas prices. Listen to this.
Speaker 6: David Pakman Miller has done a damn.
You're saying President Biden or
any president, for that matter,
has nothing to do with the price of gas.
Speaker 1: Almost nothing to do. I've
explained the three things presidents can do.
Speaker 6: So. I've told you several times today.
Things like you never played my clip.
Speaker 1: I actually have
played a number of Billy's clips,
Speaker 6: a voicemail on your show.
How would either how you because I make it
look stupid, right? But the Senate president
doesn't do with gas prices yet. Job on first
day in office. Count the Keystone Pipeline.
That's one way, in fact, gas prices.
Speaker 1: Yeah, no, unfortunately,
that's not true. Remember, Keystone pipeline
phases one through three are up and running.
What Joe Biden did was stop construction of the
fourth phase of Keystone XL. Keystone is not an
oil field. It's only a pipeline. It's a way to
transport the oil. The oil is still coming in.
It's just coming in through other
means. And the best estimates we have
are that phase four of Keystone XL when
completed, and it wouldn't even be done now.
If Biden had started continued construction, it
wouldn't even be done now, but when completed,
phase four of Keystone XL would only have
increased oil production by one percent would have
no impact on the price of gas. Sorry, Billy, we've
got a great bonus show for you today. Sign up
at Join Packman dot com to get instant access.
Unidentified: I will see you that.